j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
des bas de société vous le savez on
cherche le plus souvent à décaler de
l'actualité du jour pour prendre du
recul on remonte aussi mai dernier
manifestations
identitaires néo fascistes qui faisait
ressortir ce terme d'ultra-droite dans
les médias un mois plus tard on va
débarque de ce mot on va débattre de la
place de ces groupuscules de leurs liens
il y en a encore avec le rassemblement
national et les dangers qu'ils font
peser sur notre démocratie d'abord qui
sont ces manifestants qui étaient là le
6 mai première réponse Mathias Arès
depuis 5 ans Clément milita l'Action
française chaque année avec son
mouvement politique il rend hommage à
Jeanne d'Arc le deuxième dimanche de mai
alors quand la préfecture de police de
Paris décide d'interdire la
manifestation sur ordre du ministre de
l'intérieur c'est l'incompréhension
une personne une femme qui a défendu la
France qui a sauvé la France de
l'étranger sans Jeanne d'Arc tu vas plus
de ça c'est illégal parce que
de la République elle-même est obligée
d'honorer Jeanne d'Arc le deuxième
dimanche de mai comme le Sénat le fait
comme l'Assemblée nationale le fait
comme la mairie de pareil le fait donc
la République ne devrait pas pouvoir
nous interdire un hommage Jeanne d'Arc
qui en plus de ça ne pose aucun problème
à l'ordre public une république dont
l'action française ne veut d'ailleurs
plus quand on fait un constat historique
sur l'histoire de France on peut voir
que la monarchie en bilan d'existence a
amené la France à la première des
puissants mondiales puissance mondiale
pardon c'était le un petit peu le phare
de l'humanité on pourrait dire mais
actuellement avec la République on peut
voir que la France se fait tour à tour
dépasser par les États-Unis la Chine
bientôt ce sera la Russie le Brésil
l'Afrique du Sud voilà donc la France
aujourd'hui est en pleine un grand
éclassement comme comme le disait
Eric Zemmour durant sa campagne des
idées à l'extrême droite de l'échiquier
politique que Clément n'est pas le seul
à avoir ces dernières semaines les
images de la manif eStation du collectif
du 9 mai ont particulièrement choqué
l'opinion Gérald Darmanin accusé de
laisser faire d'ici de répondre avec
fermeté j'ai donné comme instruction au
préfet de police
que tout militants d'ultra-droite ou
d'extrême droite ou toute association
aux collectif à Paris comme partout sur
le territoire national qui déposera des
manifestations dans ce sens que vous
avez décrit prendra les préfets de
prendreont des arrêtés d'interdiction et
nous laisserons donc les tribunaux jugés
doivent savoir si la jurisprudence
permettront en effet de tenir ces
manifestations
un traitement politique quelque peu
démesuré pour Jean-Yves Camus
spécialiste de l'extrême droite qui
réfute la théorie d'une résurgence des
mouvements nationalistes il s'agit pas
évidemment
denier le caractère
néo fasciste clairement des gens qui
défilaient mais ils étaient 600 ces gens
venaient de toute la France tous les
groupuscules en fait c'était de nez
rendez vous
pour cette occasion et on avait là
finalement une photographie assez fidèle
à un instant T de ce que représente le
noyau dur de l'ultra droite aujourd'hui
en France pour autant le polit de
minimise pas la menace violente de
certains de ces groupuscules c'est toute
dernière année ont été démantelés
plusieurs réseaux de militants
ultra-droites
avec une sociologie différente
d'ailleurs des gens plus âgés des gens
ayant appartenu pour certains aux forces
de l'ordre ou à l'armée des gens qui
préparent donc des actions terroristes
le parquet national antiterroriste se
saisit désormais de ce genre d'affaires
on estime aujourd'hui en France à 1300
le nombre de militants d'extrême droite
fichiers
et je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Frédéric matoncti bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
sciences politiques à Paris implant
Sorbonne auteur de ce livre sommes-nous
devenus réac publié chez fire il manque
dans ces sa somme nous comment
sommes-nous je voyais qu'il me manquait
un élément comment sommes-nous
aujourd'hui des réac chez Fayard
Béatrice bonsoir bienvenue à vous
géographe directrice de la revue
Hérodote et vous avez dirigé cet ouvrage
l'extrême droite en Europe aux éditions
de La Découverte j'accueille également
Mathieu Molard bonsoir bonsoir oui vous
êtes rédacteur en chef à Street presse
et vous avez notamment enquêté sur ces
groupes uscules d'extrême droite ce qui
gravitent autour des risques Zemmour ou
d'un Alain Soral et d'autres Mathilde
sero évidemment est resté à mes côtés je
vais vous donner un chiffre tiens pour
commencer on parlait des fichiers avec
Mathias arez un rapport d'enquête de
l'Assemblée sur la lutte contre les
groupuscules d'extrême droite qui
décompte environ 3000 membres de
l'ultra-droite j'emploie ce terme en
début de débat parce qu'il est il
simplifie les choses c'est vrai que
mathondi est-ce que il y a une
résurgence vous vous voyez un petit quai
aux propos dans le reportage est-ce que
vous diriez vous qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux quand même je sais s'ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux mais ils
sont parce que c'est très difficile
d'avoir des chiffres etc mais ils sont
de plus en plus visibles dans l'espace
public ils sont de plus en plus ils sont
redevenus de plus en plus agressifs dans
l'espace public on a quand même une
série là d'affaires a commencé par
Saint-Brevin pour commencer mais aussi
des attaques de manifestation ce genre
de choses donc je dirais que peut-être
en chiffres absolus ils sont pas plus
nombreux mais ils sont là ils sont très
présents ils ont été très présents dans
les campagnes dans la campagne de
Zemmour par exemple donc ça me paraît
difficile de faire comme si ça avait
toujours été là au contraire enfin s'il
fallait comparer je pense qu'il faudrait
comparer d'un certain point de vue aux
années 30 même si c'est toujours très
embêtant de faire des comparaisons
historiques parce que des choses
changent bien entendu et puis il y a
aussi une pénétration de d'un certain
nombre de thématiques à partir du moment
où les idées de droite et endroit
radical ce sont
banalisés d'un certain point de vue
comme le montre les débats là en cours
actuels on voit bien que fatalement il y
a comme un appel du vide pour avoir des
choses de plus en plus radicales et ce à
quoi s'attaque on va dire l'ultra droite
pour aller vite bon on voit bien en gros
c'est les les personnes ont demandé
etc enfin on voit bien quels sont les
cibles de toute manière est-ce que
Béatrice Gibelin les les attentats du 13
novembre à Paris on provoqué un afflux
de nouveaux de nouveaux adeptes en
quelque sorte est-ce que ça peut être
l'une des explications c'est possible
j'en ai pas la possibilité j'ai pas fait
d'enquête qui permettent de dire très
clairement que ça s'est passé comme ça
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les
attentats ont alimenté la représentation
de la détestation de ce qui était le
monde arabo-musulman par rapport à ce
qui est le monde du néocrétien
c'est quelque chose je crois qui est une
composante
importante
dans une partie de l'ultra-droite je
veux dire si on regarde les cathos
intégrés sont bien est-ce que c'est
d'ultra-doirs quand on regarde sur Vita
on peut peut-être quand même se dire que
on est vraiment dans une droite très
très radicale on va dire que c'est l'une
des composantes c'est une des
composantes mais elles sont multiples
mais je pense que la composante si vous
voulez chrétienne la référence au
judéo-chrétiens pour moi elle est très
très liée au fait qu'il y ait eu les
attentats musulmans c'est le Zemmour
c'est là-dessus qu'il a joué en jouant
complètement sur la crête GMT
judéo-chrétiens beaucoup beaucoup ça
d'ailleurs la carte du vote Zemmour et
elle est assez intéressante à regarder
avec une lecture le là où je trouve
encore des catholiques pratiquants et
justement si on essaye je vais faire un
peu de géographie Mathieu Mollat alors
sont souvent des hommes
majoritairement même si un phénomène
nouveau
en tout cas qui s'est renforcé on a des
groupuscules identitaires féminins
d'accord donc
déjà déjà ça ça me il y a une idée reçue
pour moi c'était que des hommes donc il
y a quand même quelque chose alors c'est
très masculin évidemment mais il y a des
gros muscu je pense à Nemesis qui est un
gros muscu identitaire qui peut être
dans l'idéologie comparable la
génération identitaire et qui
s'exprime sur la voie publique utilise
d'ailleurs des stratégies assez
similaires à celle de génération
identitaire c'est-à-dire de créer des
happnings et créer aussi de la tension
débarquer dans une manifestation
féministe en disant le principal danger
pour les femmes c'est les hommes
musulmans et ils savent que ça va elles
savent que ça va créer une tension et
voilà mais donc pas que masculin donc
grande majorité d'hommes mais il y a
aussi quelques femmes est-ce qu'ils sont
plutôt
dans des grandes villes dans des milieux
très urbains ruraux qu'est-ce qu'on sait
de ça alors ce qui est un des phénomènes
intéressants en ce moment c'est que le
territoire français est très largement
couvert il y a toujours eu l'ion qui
était un bastion historique de l'extrême
droite extra-parlementaire Paris aussi
mais aujourd'hui on voit des
groupuscules violents à Valence on voit
des groupuscules violents à Angers dans
des villes moyennes ils sont très
présents et après il y a un glissement
pour moi c'est toute dernière année
entre de type idéologique et donc de
nature les militants qu'on voit au CNFM
habillé tout en noir etc très bodybuildé
très musclé c'est ce qu'on appelle des
nationaux révolutionnaires c'est des
militants de Néo fascistes et c'est des
groupes de bagarres c'est des gens
l'idéologie bon ils sont néophytes mais
c'est pas des gens qui écrivent des
livres ces gens qui vont à la castagne
quand il y a quelques années c'était la
mouvance identitaire qui elle visait
quand même à peser sur le débat public
général génération identitaire voulait
insuffler son idologie au RN et plus
largement à droite et plus globalement
dans la société eux ils s'en foutent ils
veulent se taper ils veulent ils
cherchent la bagarre alors je l'ai dit
il y a ce mot ultra-droite on va prendre
le temps finalement de l'analyser faire
peut-être un peu de sémantique grâce à
Tam traduis qui va nous rejoindre une
nouvelle fois sur ce plateau rebonsoir
Tam d'où vient le mot et qu'est-ce qu'il
désigne exactement alors c'est un mot
que l'on voit utiliser un peu partout
dans les médias comme un synonyme
d'extrême droite extra parlementaire et
dans l'usage c'est largement popularisé
ces dernières années ce n'est pas du
tout ce qu'il désignait initialement le
chercheur Nicolas le bourg qui est
spécialisé sur l'extrême droite
l'explique très bien au départ c'est un
terme qui était employé par les
renseignements généraux en 1994 il y a
une réforme une réforme qui empêche les
RG désormais d'enquêter sur les parties
politiques en revanche ils doivent
continuer à surveiller des potentiels
terroristes des potentiels activistes et
c'est alors qu'ils se mettent à utiliser
ce terme le terme d'ultra-droite qui
renvoie donc aux ultras d'Algérie et qui
leur permet donc de différencier de
catégoriser l'extrême droite légale
comme parti politique qu'ils ne suivent
pas de ces groupes qui suivent d'accord
c'est une expression que nous
journaliste que les médias ont reprises
petit à petit et l'expression elle a été
popularisée dans les médias mais c'est
assez récent c'est seulement depuis une
dizaine d'années massivement utilisé
elle a encore Nicolas lebour date son
utilisation à 2012 et aux attentats de
Mohamed Merah à Toulouse au moment où
les médias reprennent d'ailleurs le
terme employé par les enquêteurs qui
pendant un moment ne savent pas si le
tueur et d'une piste islamiste ou si
c'est la piste qui vient de l'ultra
droite et le chercheur Jean-Yves Camus
lui et bien a dit qu'ensuite on a
continué à utiliser ce terme notamment
dans le cadre du mariage pour tous au
moment où on observe des débordements
extrémistes et on peut le voir il y a
d'ailleurs ce type d'articles qui
reprennent ce vocabulaire on en vient au
coeur de la question pourquoi
l'utilisation de ce terme ultra droite
est quand même problématique ça peut
être problématique le premier problème
c'est qu'ils mélange tout le monde il
fait un gloubiboulga il range dans la
même catégorie des grands pustus qui
sont quand même assez différents vous
venez d'en parler les Identitaires les
néophytes les néo-nazis les royalistes
les catholiques intégristes alors que
tous ces mouvements peuvent et bien
obéir à des idéologies différentes et
donc c'était un terme qui est devenu
très fourre-tout et qui nous ex aussi
parfois de l'effort d'être précis de
bien catégoriser nous quand on voit par
exemple un mouvement et qu'on doit le
qualifier dans un article c'est aussi un
terme qui est plus abstrait qui peut à
moindre rire le dernier exemple en date
et bien c'est par exemple cette
manifestation dont on a bien sûr
beaucoup parlé lorsque le préfet de
Paris a refusé interdire ce défilé
néonazi fasciste le 6 mai à Paris la
préférée employer le terme d'ultra
droite c'est plus politiquement correct
et cela a plus acceptable sa décision
donc c'est une facilité intellectuelle
et qui facilité qui atténue une réalité
qui peut aller jusqu'à devenir inexact
donc difficulté problème intellectuelle
mais aussi politique oui car ce terme il
permet aussi de différencier désormais
l'extrême droite en considérant que cela
reflète des parties l'égalistes et sans
violence des mouvements de l'ultra à
droite qui seraient donc eux violents or
et bien là-dessus ce n'est pas vrai non
plus c'est beaucoup plus poreux que ça
on va prendre un exemple les catégories
catholiques intégristes qui sont
englobés dans le terme du TAS
d'ultra-droite ne sont pas tous violents
et à l'inverse des militants reconquêtes
par exemple très présent lors des
manifestations très violentes de
Saint-Brevin il y a pas du coup de façon
étanche les violents d'un côté les
non-violants de l'autre cette barrière
sémantique elle n'a pas lieu d'être
d'autant qu'en distinguant et bien
l'ultra droite de l'extrême droite ça
crée une catégorie donc à la droite de
l'extrême droite qui a pour effet de
recentrer politiquement l'extrême droite
et on est passé on le voit ces dernières
années de la dédiabolisation à la
banalisation à la normalisation du RN et
les mots que l'on emploie on leur parle
de responsabilité on t'accompagné en
tout cas ce mouvement merci beaucoup Tam
c'était pas passionnant de votre côté
Mathieu Molard est-ce que vous employez
ce terme non je l'emploi pas pour ces
raisons là notamment pour ces raisons là
je dis extrême droite extra
parlementaire parce que pour moi il y a
pas de frontières étanche entre le RN on
sait que Marine Le Pen a des liens
personnels et financiers avec des
militants qui ont défilé avec les
néo-fascistes le 6 mai à l'occasion du
CNFM
reconquête
à dans ses rangs de nombreux militants
venant de génération identitaire un
groupe muscul qui a été interdit il y a
quelques années par exemple
Cédric matoncif sur le terme
ultra droite évidemment nous on l'a mis
dans notre tir parce que c'est c'est on
aurait peut-être pas dû mais on s'est
creusé on a ici à faire bon bref quand
on a peu de mots pour faire un titre
c'est compliqué de mettre toute la
variété des catégories de ces
groupuscules on peut le comprendre
est-ce que vous l'employer ce terme pas
vraiment mais c'est pas non plus
directement mon objet moi je travaille
j'ai plus travaillé sur l'extrême droite
parlementaire que sur l'extrême droite
extra parlementaire je trouve que cette
formulation d'extrême droite
extra-parlementaire et très pratique
parce que elle permet bien de désigner
et tout en même temps sans oublier comme
vous le disiez qui peut y avoir des
liens en effet qui peut y avoir des
services d'ordre par exemple qui sont
qui viennent de cette extrême droite
extra parlementaire il y a aussi
tout bêtement des réseaux qui sont assez
communs par exemple guide donc moi je
préfère j'aurais tendance à dire ça vaut
le coup d'appeler les choses par leur
nom et d'être un peu un peu précis mais
c'est vrai aussi que ces pratiques
d'avoir une catégorie pour tout par
moment
votre avis là-dessus la batterie
gibblain est peut-être aussi parce qu'on
va en parler dans un instant je voudrais
pas déplorer la
l'édito va nous faire Mathilde mais les
liens entre le RN et
et c'est ultra droite je vais continuer
d'utiliser cette cette facilité
il y a quand même quand on utilise ce
mot et quand on parle de ces
groupuscules
d'extrême droite violence ou pas ça
participe de la dédiabolisation du
rassemblement national c'est ça qui est
intéressant aussi dans notre chaque est
intéressant et qui pose problème bien
évidemment mais ce qu'on m'a quand un
terme s'impose comme ça comme il s'est
imposé ultra-droite on dit toujours
c'est valise c'est des mots valises bon
oui d'accord mais le fait qu'on les
utilise ils répondent à un besoin
c'est pas facile de l'extra de droite
extra parlementaire quand vous êtes vous
journaliste dans la concision et au fond
un peu dans marquer les esprits avancés
c'est important si vous commencez à
faire à chaque fois les nuances de ces
différents groupes à mon avis vous
resterez pas aussi très longtemps donc
ça vous oblige à faire dans chaque
phrase
identitaire royalise mais au fasciste
etc etc donc c'est bon à droite ça
répond à quelque chose qui est
incontestablement une évolution du Front
National au départ le Front national
c'est quoi c'est un regroupement en fait
on va dire d'ultra droite qui met à leur
tête quelqu'un qui est présentable qui
s'appelle Jean-Marie Le Pen bon c'est le
moins pire du lot et donc on va le
mettre en avant
si vous voulez en canard d'appel bon à
partir de ce moment-là ça se met en
place et puis
j'allais dire les réussites le fait de
gagner des élections le fait d'arriver
d'ailleurs où ce qu'on tourne des
élections présidentielles de 2002 tout
ceci change évidemment leur propre
perception du rôle et au fond accéder au
pouvoir devient un objectif et pour
accéder au pouvoir il faut changer
évidemment de costumes on peut pas
rester avec ce même type de discours
donc c'est pas tellement
si j'ose dire si on est arrivé à
l'ultra-droite c'est effectivement parce
que le Front national petit à petit
entre sa création dans les années 70 et
puis cette percée dans les années 90 ça
fait quand même 20 ans et maintenant ça
fait 30 ans il a incontestablement
évolué et c'est pas parce qu'on dirait
jamais le gras droite que l'extrême
droite ne serait pas aujourd'hui
banaliser des diaboliques
c'est amusant parce qu'en préparant
l'émission on s'est rendu compte que ça
fait exactement 5 ans aujourd'hui que le
Front national c'est rebaptisé
rassemblement national Mathilde cette
prise de distance on va dire avec
l'ultra-droite c'est un élément
constitutif de je remplace ce terme de
la dédiabolisation du parti on pourrait
même dire de la
médicalisation de ce parti Marine Le Pen
depuis toujours on l'a dit elle a
recruté parmi ces groupuscules
d'ultra-droites quantité d'électeurs de
sympathisants même des cadres de son
parti et pourtant depuis plusieurs mois
elle affiche un certain zèle à chaque
fois qu'il a des regroupements par
exemple qui tournent mal ou qui font les
gros titres elle veut absolument s'en
dissocier de plus en plus fortement
jusqu'à très récemment d'ailleurs elle
ne demandait que la dissolution des
groupuscules dit antifasciste ou de
l'ultra gauche et désormais sont partis
par exemple réclament la dissolution du
guide donc c'est une c'est une posture
politique évidemment qui consiste à
prendre ces distances avec toute forme
de de violence militante de radicalité
et aussi à mettre un signe égal entre
les groupuscules qu'on peut dire d'ultra
gauche et ceux de l'ultra droite mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire des liens
voilà il ne faut pas s'y tromper puisque
des liens persistants existent entre
entre le RN et le but par exemple
exemple on pense évidemment à deux
figures qui sont Axel lousto ou Frédéric
Châtillon qui sont des amis de jeunesse
de Marine Le Pen qu'elle préférait
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui oublier tout du
moins publicment mais qui ont bien sûr
vrai à ces campagnes aujourd'hui elle
cherche à gommer toutes porosité aussi
idéologique entre sa famille politique
et les tests défendus par ces
groupuscules alors qu'il y a encore
moins de deux ans elle soutenait par
exemple génération
identitaire est-ce que c'est gagnant
politiquement alors on me l'a dit c'est
une brique dans sa stratégie de
normalisation Marine Le Pen de plus en
plus cherche à incarner l'ordre et même
la stabilité des institutions et l'état
de droit donc ça on fait partie elle a
fait le ménage dans son parti elle a
écarté depuis plusieurs années ce
qu'elle appelait les brebis galeuses
qu'on retrouvait souvent dans des listes
aux élections locales elle fait le
calcul qu'il est désormais plus payant
ou plus payant aujourd'hui de se
recentrer à perdre dans notre côté des
militants qui pourraient être davantage
nationalistes ou séduits par des thèses
aussi racialistes et qui se tournent
justement vers Éric Zemmour et vers
reconquête ou là la sympathie est plus
assumée avec certains groupuscules
d'ailleurs récemment Marion maréchal a
considéré que la violence de
l'ultra-droite était je la cite des
rizoire et cette conséquence pour en
terminer pour Marine Le Pen ce serait de
ne plus apparaître comme une candidate
anti-système ce sur quoi pourtant est la
surfé depuis des années maintenant merci
beaucoup Mathilde Mathieu Molard est-ce
que c'est extrême droite violentes bon
je voilà j'emploie ces termes-là est-ce
qu'elle a toujours ses entrées peut
scinder mais au rassemblement national
et chez Eric Zemmour oui alors elle a
cherric Zemmour les portes sont grandes
ouvertes elle est à la maison certains
cadres de ce mouvement Damien Rieu était
un cadre de génération identité un
groupe muscul qui des dissous alors
c'est clair c'est affiché
ORL c'est plus compliqué c'est à dire
que les liens existent il le RN tente
comme ça vient d'être dit de les masquer
c'est bien là ils existent Châtillon
Loustau sont actionnaires d'une société
qui est le prince principale entreprise
qui travaille pour le rassemblement
national au Parlement européen donc il y
a des liens commerciaux c'est le monde
qui a révélé ça
à tout un tas d'événements on voit
apparaître des gens issus de cette
mouvance là après moi j'ai une petite
anecdote qui illustre bien la différence
entre les deux c'est il y a eu le
meeting de Villepinte pendant la
campagne électorale qui a été très
médiatisée où on a vu des gens pour
certains qui étaient toujours assez de
manifestation là
tabasser violemment des militants des
SOS Racisme qui faisaient un apnée
c'était un meeting d'Éric Zemmour
et c'est mit tétons étaient dans la
salle donc ils étaient à l'intérieur
cinq ans plus tôt j'ai été présent dans
la même salle pour un meeting cette fois
de Marine Le Pen dans la campagne
présidentielle précédente il est même
militant le même groupuscule qui
existait déjà 5 ans plus tôt ils étaient
là mais ils étaient pas dans la salle
ils étaient devant la salle et il
faisait à l'extérieur à l'extérieur et
il faisait un espèce de service d'ordre
parallèle en lien évidemment avec le
service d'ordre officiel du
rassemblement national ils étaient là
mais à la frontière c'est ça la
différence entre les deux d'accord donc
si je vous entends il y a une double
différence ils sont passés à l'intérieur
ils sont passés du rassemblement
national à reconquête bon ils sont
toujours RN aussi ils sont toujours des
deux côtés alors votre analyse là-dessus
Frédéric madame m'attontie parce que
effectivement il y a ce on a bien
compris cette volonté de de gommer ces
liens ou cette partie de de l'histoire
est-ce que c'est seulement de
l'affichage ou est-ce qu'il y a
effectivement des personnages
encombrants qui ont été virés du
rassemblement national le FN puis le RN
a toujours fait ça c'est à dire que dès
que c'était trop visible qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui venait vraiment du
mouvement fasciste ou qui faisait un qui
faisait une intervention beaucoup plus
vulgaire raciste etc la contrainte était
telle qu'il fallait sortir cette
personne pour éviter justement d'avoir
des soucis y compris des soucis
juridiques bon ça toujours été donc de
la même manière dans la formation du FN
dans la formation des cadres puis
j'imagine maintenant dans la formation
du RN il y a cette idée qu'il faut
surtout avoir un langage policier qui ne
va pas laisser prise justement à des à
pouvoir se faire taxer de fasciste etc
si on regarde ce qui s'est passé là
récemment très récemment au début de
semaine avec Elisabeth borne d'un
certain point de vue Elisabeth borne a
cassé le jeu c'est à dire en rappelant
cette histoire des origines pétées
voilà de de héritier de Pétain du RN
elle a rappelé une histoire que le Front
National et le RN ont toujours tenté de
masquer et je pense que nous on a
intérêt en tant que chercheur en tant
que journaliste en tant que citoyen à
faire très attention à ces stratégies de
dédiabolisation parce que c'est vraiment
un travail très constant que fait que
fait Marine Le Pen et elle a une chance
sur le je trouve que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur les femmes en politique
tout ce qui nuit généralement aux femmes
en politique c'est à dire qu'on va les
ramener à leur famille alors à leurs
vêtements alors
leurs enfants etc elle c'est quelque
chose sur lequel elle capitalise et sur
lequel elle construit donc elle elle
raconte sa vie de famille elle la montre
ses chats etc etc pour adoucir son image
pour adoucir son image pour se
différencier de celui qui dirigeait le
parti auparavant et qui était Jean-Marie
Le Pen c'est-à-dire elle retourne le
Stig et ça je pense qu'on a intérêt à
être très prudent avec ça sur
l'idéologie la capillarité là on parlait
de capillarité dans les finalement les
les les hommes les services d'ordre et
cetera et cetera dans l'idéologie est-ce
que vous voyez une capillarité qui
existe encore aujourd'hui entre allez je
vais reprendre ultra droite et
rassemblement national oui elle est elle
existe elle est simplement cherche à la
contrôler de la part du rassemblement
national mais c'est bien pour ça qu'on
cadre bien serré un certain nombre
d'élus souvenez-vous de ce qui s'est
passé au discours quand on a ouvert la
nouvelle législature le Doyen a été un
élu du rassemblement national et qui a
fait une sortie sur l'os qui était
franchement pas prévu du tout au
programme à ce moment-là bon il y en
aura pas d'autres
aussitôt on a resserré les boulons et
celui-là il a pu la parole donc
leur idéologie de fond moi je pense elle
n'a pas changé c'est toujours une
idéologie ou on voit à la limite les
blancs en français de choses chrétiens
supérieurs aux autres il y a une
idéologie de base qui reste de mon point
de vue quand même raciste et qui ça n'a
pas changé et la réaction d'Elisabeth
borne quand même il faut souvenir de sa
propre histoire familiale où on a appris
récemment que son père avait été déporté
lui aussi et qu'il en était rentré cassé
pour le restant de sa vie et donc elle
ne peut pas passer là-dessus elle ne
peut pas passer sur des formes de
négationnisme sur des Duras four
crématoires alors on ne dit plus des
choses comme ça bien évidemment mais ce
qui ne veut pas dire que le fond si vous
voulez et était
lavé plus blanc et tout ça a disparu moi
je ne le pense pas il suffit de gratter
un peu extrême droite violente qui pèse
dans le débat public on l'a évoqué
rapidement menace
agression c'est Patrick hair le
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
qui le rappelait à la première ministre
était lors de question au gouvernement
juste après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin on écoute Patrick caner
Saint-Brévin c'est aussi le signe d'une
résurgence des violences de l'extrême
droite depuis plusieurs semaines ces
actes de terrorisme intellectuel et
physique se sont multipliés pour
empêcher les maires qui le veulent de
prendre part à l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile madame la Première ministre on
ne peut mettre sur un pied d'égalité
d'extrême droite et d'autres formes de
contestation l'extrême droite que ce
soit au sein de nos institutions ou dans
le cadre d'action clandestine et
l'ennemi mortel de notre démocratie
l'État ne peut rester larmes aux pieds
face à ses menaces allez-vous engager ce
combat pour défendre les élus de la
République Mathieu voilà est-ce que ce
qui s'est passé à Saint-Brevin ça peut
finalement donner des idées à d'autres
groupuscules d'extrême droite finalement
autour de ces notamment de ces cas-là de
ces centres d'accueil des demandeurs
d'Asie alors ça a marché une fois on va
continuer comment peut-être au contraire
ouh là là on est trop sous les pro il
faut qu'on fasse un petit pas
exactement la même analyse d'accord
c'est une action politique qui vise à
chercher un lieu symbolique qui est pour
montrer mettre en lumière l'invasion
migratoire de nos campagnes par les
migrants c'est qui est derrière ça c'est
les Identitaires c'est un truc très
identitaire c'est illustré la théorie du
grand rond-point cette théorie conspie
fumeuse dont on a parlé très souvent et
ben ça au Brévin ça illustre
physiquement ça on installe dans nos
campagnes un centre de migrants donc des
réseaux qui sont articulés autour d'Eric
Zemmour ont organisé une mobilisation
politique idéologique là-dessus d'accord
ce sont greffés à ça des militants plus
radicaux parce que il y a cette porosité
entre l'extrême droite et pour reprendre
le terme du jour l'ultra droite
moi je vois plus la violence de
l'extrême droite extra parlementaire
pendant la campagne présidentielle où on
a vu des coups de couteau des agressions
de militants politiques des ratonades
dans la rue qui toujours été moins
médiatisés mais qui ont été extrêmement
nombreuses dans la rue et pendant toute
cette campagne et qui existe encore
aujourd'hui à Lyon à Paris régulièrement
et avec un mouvement qui était un peu le
porte-drapeau de de cette extrême droite
avec des coups de poings dans les années
70 pardon c'était le guide on a déjà
cité le guide groupe Union défense je me
souvenais plus de ce que ça voulait dire
j'ai rafraîchi ma mémoire cet après-midi
et bien il a été réactivé l'an dernier
et il sévit de nouveau dans certaines
universités écoutez cette étudiante qui
participait à une manifestation
dénonçant l'extrême droite cet appareil
elle est visible de plus en plus dans
les universités notamment à Rennes là il
y a 10 jours il y a eu une attaque de
trois étudiants et étudiantes par un
groupe d'extrême droite donc ça ça
commence à se ressentir dans les
universités il y a également le retour
du guide donc qui commence à revenir
dans les universités bon tabasser les
étudiants et étudiants gratuitement qui
vont juste décoller des affiches ou
manifester leur mécontentement en tout
cas de cette montée de l'extrême droite
et ça c'est quelque chose que nous on
réprime fortement et on est totalement
contre qui est en train de se passer
parce qu'encore une fois l'université
censé être un lieu de bien-être et de
sécurité ou ces groupes puisque le
destrème droite en tout cas qui prône la
haine n'ont pas leur place batterie
Gibelin si on parle du guide je trouve
que c'était intéressant d'avoir dans ce
chapitre parce que là aussi
historiquement ça remonte à la fondation
du Front national les liens entre le
guide et
on sait bien que les sacs de droits
étaient quand même des lieux dans
lesquels l'extrême droite se portait
bien
puisqu'on vous rappelez une anecdote moi
je vous en donner une autre au début de
la création du centre expérimental de
Vincennes un des grands leaders on va
dire d'une droite radicale de ce qui
sera le Front National qui s'appelait
François Duprat assez trouvé inscrit à
l'université du centre expérimental de
Vincennes et qui a subi une fois qu'il a
été découvert les foudres de l'extrême
gauche avec une violence j'étais
étudiante à l'époque qui m'avait
profondément marqué parce que c'est pas
des enfants de cœur non plus donc on
était arrivé à une situation extrêmement
tendue donc on avait bien il avait pris
un risque en venant dans ce centre
expérimental qui était bien évidemment
très à gauche et on avait des liens
forts de l'extrême gauche avec le monde
universitaire
incontestablement et en particulier tout
ce qui était trop de skyste qui est
umaïste qui était très important et qui
était aussi très intransigeant vous
allez si vous étiez pas d'accord avec
eux dans une discussion c'était assez
douloureux quand même et de la même
façon vous aviez une extrême droite
alors je sais pas un parallèle identique
je vais pas aller jusque là bien
évidemment mais dans les milieux
universitaires les tensions et je vais
dire la domination idéologique et par un
peu comment on prenait j'allais dire la
domination par exemple dans un office ça
c'était quand même quelque chose de
toute la fin important alors le but lui
il allait effectivement jusqu'au coup de
poing donc c'était
un peu plus nettement plus violent
encore que ce que pouvait être l'extrême
gauche mais pour avoir été étudiante au
centre expérimental de Vincennes je peux
vous assurer que c'était quand même
toujours très musclé je reviens à cette
manifestation du 6 mai donc groupuscule
royaliste néo fasciste autorisé en plein
Paris le gouvernement qui se justifie à
l'époque par l'absence de risque de
troubles à l'ordre public pour expliquer
pourquoi ça ça n'a pas été interdifié
avec ma tontie est-ce que
on peut imaginer que le gouvernement a
été lui aussi surpris par le non si s'il
est voilà s'il est servi de
renseignements travaillent bien s'il est
surpris bon par ailleurs moi je suis
frappé quand même de l'image qu'on voit
là avec cet homme masqué c'est-à-dire
que en théorie c'est absolument interdit
d'avoir un visage masqué dans l'espace
public donc rien que ça et pose en soi
problème en cette manif quand on regarde
les images elle a été sagement encadrée
rien que ça
aurait légitimer l'interdiction je sais
pas ce que je dis mais ça pose problème
en soi et faire comme enfin il a quand
même fallu attendre qu'il y a une levée
de bouclier sur les réseaux sociaux de
la part des des partis politiques pour
que on se rende compte que c'était un
problème que cette manif était autorisée
d'autant que c'est un moment ça ne se
passe pas à n'importe quel moment ça
veut dire ça se passe au moment du
mouvement de contre la réforme des
retraites ou beaucoup de manifs sont
interdites où il y a des interdictions
un petit peu ridicules sur les
dispositifs portatifs sonores et donc
interdire des concerts de casseroles et
autorisés ce genre de choses c'est vrai
que ça fait un drôle d'effet et donc
c'est toujours quand il est le dos mur
que le gouvernement en particulier que
d'armes le ministre de l'Intérieur
Darmanin réagit et c'est un peu la même
chose sur les interdictions moi je dis
pas qu'il va franchement dissoudre
génération
identitaire de toute façon ils se
reforme sous un autre nom sous une autre
forme bon voilà ça n'a pas grande
importance mais ça prend acte quand même
du danger que représente ces personnes
dans l'espace public parce que si on
regarde toutes les interventions de
génération identitaires elles sont quand
même très problématiques que ce soit les
interventions à la frontière italienne
que ce soit les montées sur le point
empêcher des constructions de mosquées
ou ce genre de choses ça pose quand même
un certain nombre de problèmes et j'a
qu'en plus on leur a offert enfin je
veux dire Thaïs des scufchons qui était
la porte-parole on l'a vu sur des
plateaux de télé tout à fait alors je
dirais pas respectable mais on l'a vu
j'irai pas jusque là mais on l'a vu sur
des plateaux de télé venir comme si elle
était une leader politique ordinaire
vous parliez de juste du ministère de
l'Intérieur est-ce que est-ce que les
interpellations dans le cas de
manifestation plus ou moins violente
est-ce que vous vous considérez que ça
suit
il y a eu des arrestations récentes à
Lyon me semble-t-il à la suite de
l'attaque d'un bar ou d'un club d'un bar
antifasciste c'est ça la suite je sais
je sais pas
trop où ça en est en fait le truc c'est
que il y a la réponse politique
elle est souvent sous parce que il y a
les projecteurs médiatiques qui sont
braqués sur un sujet le Sénat Fame cette
manifestation ce monsieur cagoulé c'est
une manifestation qui a lieu tous les
ans moi je l'ai découverte en 2015 cette
manifestation là c'est toujours à la
même date ça dépend quand on me le
weekend mais c'est
il commémore le décès d'un militant
nationaliste révolutionnaire dans le
cadre d'une courbe poursuite avec la
police à l'époque l'avocate de certains
de ces militants c'était Marine Le Pen
quand elle était jeune avocate donc
encore tu te passerelle mais passons là
d'un coup il y a eu un certain nombre de
médias à qui parce qu'il y a une
résurgence de ce courant là Nationaliste
Révolutionnaire promis les projecteurs
là-dessus nous sur StreetPress on a
publié une enquête là-dessus pour dire
voilà les identitaires sont en perte de
vitesse les nationaux et évolutionnaires
prennent le lead il y a eu libération
qui a fait ça une Médiapart qui a fait
une enquête voilà et là d'un coup le
gouvernement doit réagir le gouvernement
doit réagir les dissolutions le col de
l'échelle c'est génération
identitaire qui fait sa stratégie qui
est toujours la même pour avoir discuter
un certain nombre de fois avec des
militants de génération et
d'identitaires leur modèle c'est
Greenpeace c'est à dire que l'idée c'est
de faire du Happening symbolique pour
peser sur le débat public avec
évidemment dans ces rangs des militants
violents mais c'est pas son ADN prof
qu'est ce qui se passe déjà
rappelez-vous le col de l'échelle c'est
quoi dans les Alpes ils disent on va
empêcher les migrants de passer la
frontière il n'empêche personne ils sont
10 au milieu de ce qui le coût
médiatique fonctionne voilà la gauche
réagit en disant regardez il y a une
Milus dans les Alpes non il y a 10
Guignols avec un drapeau sur les pistes
de ski
la droite qui veut pas être en reste
monte il y a une course à l'échalote et
on dessine mais alors c'est compliqué ça
parce que soit on en parle pas et on va
on va nous nous reprocher de de ne pas
avoir tiré la sonnette d'alarme soit on
en parle et on va faire de la publicité
vous voyez ce que je veux dire non mais
quelle réponse on apporte la question
c'est on réagit beaucoup parfois fort et
le résultat en fait rien il y a de
leader du guide dont on a parlé il
s'appelle Marc de cacret Valmeinier
c'est un jeune homme de bonne famille
ultra-violent déjà condamné comme il a
été condamné il a une interdiction de
paraître dans les deux tiers des
arrondissements de Paris contrôle
judiciaire qu'il ne respecte absolument
jamais il le repérait à des manifs tout
le temps et pourtant on le laisse en
liberté là il y a une réponse concrète
possible qui n'est pas médiatique qui
n'est pas dans l'actualité dans un
agenda mais qui est possible alors je
voudrais savoir jusqu'où peut aller la
violence et je vous propose
d'entendre justement le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin on en parle
beaucoup dans dans ce débat qui lui
parle des attentats qui ont été déjoués
par la police là en l'occurrence on est
en décembre 2022 juste après l'attaque
contre un centre culturel kurde à Paris
il y avait eu trois morts et trois
blessés
il était connu des services judiciaires
mais il n'était pas fiché comme étant
quelqu'un
d'ultra droite ou un extrémiste qui
participerait à des réunions ou dans des
organisations que nous avons parlé en
dissoute je rappelle que nous avons
déjoué depuis que je suis ministre de
l'Intérieur 9 attentats présumé d'ultra
droite donc cette menace évidemment
existe elle est extrêmement importante
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire plusieurs
fois que nous avons dissout 11
associations ou vos muscu d'ultra
droites ou d'extrême droite et ce
monsieur ne faisait partie d'aucune à
l'heure où je vous parle d'aucune de ces
de ces organisations dissoutent alors
effectivement ça rejoint et je reste
avec vous Mathieu Molard parce que une
dizaine d'attentats déjoués d'une mise
de l'intérêt comment ils sont surveillés
quel type de quel type d'attentat on
parle là déjà c'est pas les mêmes
groupuscules c'est là où il se trompe
complètement à mon sens c'est que il y a
l'idée erronée que entre la violence de
rue qui peut amener jusqu'à la mort de
l'extrême droite extra parlementaire et
l'attentat c'est une et en fait c'est
une différence de nature c'est pas les
mêmes groupes c'est pas les mêmes gens
ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont pas passés
à un moment dans un groupe dans un autre
mais alors qui fait les attentats c'est
le groupe plus âgés moins structurés
moins liés avec des Atos des structures
et des mouvements politiques c'est ce
que disait monsieur Camus dans votre
sujet en tout début d'émission c'est des
réseaux qui sont très durs à identifier
parce qu'ils sont moins liés à des
mouvements
identifiés et présente le paysage depuis
longtemps et eux par contre il peuvent
mener au terrorisme et ça c'est quelque
chose qui existe il y a eu plusieurs
attentats qui ont été déjoués
effectivement et d'ailleurs c'est plutôt
quelque chose que le renseignement prend
assez au sérieux ils ont mis longtemps à
se mettre dessus parce que le
renseignement c'est beaucoup focus c'est
sur le terrorisme islamiste on comprend
pourquoi ils ont eu du retard à la même
image sur le terrorisme d'extrême droite
puis à un moment sous l'impulsion de
Monsieur Nunez qui prend pas toujours
des décisions avec quelqu'un je suis
d'accord mais qui là à mon avis a
vraiment initié le truc quand il était
secrétaire d'État au sein du
gouvernement ils ont pris le sujet en
main et il y a une surveillance assez
étroite et on voit que des attaques sont
déjà alors je termine par les l'action
du gouvernement les dissolutions qui ont
été prononcées 2019 il y a 8
dissolutions dont celle du patient
social on a parlé de génération
identitaire dissolution 2021 l'an
dernier le groupe les oies et cette
année Bordeaux nationalistes vous vous
disiez Frédéric mathoni que ça sert
peut-être pas à grand chose mais qu'il
faut quand même les prendre ces
décisions d'abord parce que je trouve
que c'est toujours bien de mettre un
coup d'arrêt et de dire ceci pose
problème bon mais par ailleurs quand je
disais que ça ne servait pas à grand
chose c'est c'est le fait que bah il se
reforment sous un autre nom là j'ai lu
ce matin sans doute comme vous l'article
dans la montagne où c'était hier sur ce
qui se passe à Clermont avec la
structuration de l'ultra-droite autour
d'un mouvement qui s'appelle Clermont
non conforme et qui a l'air d'essayer de
fédérer absolument tous les petits
morceaux de l'ultra droite après sur ce
qu'on était en train de dire sur le
danger ou pas le don enfin le terroriste
pas terroriste bon quand même par
exemple une association comme Utopia 56
qui s'occupe des personnes ont
demandeurs d'Asie et qui a installé des
demandeurs d'asile dans une école à
Paris
raconte qu'elle est harcelée
quotidiennement ça il faut pas
non plus et par l'ultra droite bien
entendu merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vais
rappeler le titre de vos livres Béatrice
Gibelin l'extrême droite en Europe vous
allez dirigé cet ouvrage cette position
de la découverte Frédéric Mathon qui
commence sommes-nous devenus réac qui
est donc publié chez Fayard et Mathieu
voilà on peut vous lire sur le site
StreetPress avec des enquêtes au long
cours merci à tous merci beaucoup
Mathilde d'avoir participé à cette
émission la semaine prochaine Laetitia
crupa revient les mardis et je dis on
sera ravi de vous accueillir pour
participer évidemment à nos débats
politiques vous pouvez nous retrouver
également en replay nos émissions tous
les programmes de la chaîne sur la
plateforme Public Sénat point FR et puis
notez aussi le rendez-vous de la
matinale oralement signé on va parler
d'Ukraine elle reçoit Michel Goya et
Jean Lopez auteur de l'ours et le renard
histoire immédiate de la guerre en
Ukraine belle soirée à toutes et à tous
je vous dis à lundi merci de votre
fidélité
[Musique]